just because an actor has landed their
next big role doesn't necessarily mean
they're going to make it to the big
screen some of Hollywood's biggest
actors have been kicked off projects for
any number of reasons from egotistical
feuds to executive meddling to
frustrations with the direction the
movie is taking one way or another here
are a few actors who were fired after
filming began belgian actor jean-claude
van damme was right on the cusp of
superstardom when he landed a role
opposite Irish warts mega in 1987 s
predator it sounds like the perfect
casting with the renowned martial
artists seeming like he'd be able to
easily stand alongside the likes of
co-stars Carl Weathers and Jesse Ventura
but while that may be true van Damme was
never up for a part on predators special
ops team instead he was meant to play
the predator itself Steve Johnson the
special effects artist behind predators
alien creature described the movie's
brief relationship with Van Damme as a
hilarious comedy of errors in which no
party knew exactly what the other was
expecting according to Johnson no one
had informed Van Damme that the role of
the predator was practically a glorified
stuntman I told them it wouldn't work
they wanted to just tell the guy to hop
around like a frog and it was John
Claude Van Damme who had no idea what
he's getting into
Johnson explained that Van Damme was
furious and dispirited about spending
the entire movie inside a clunky
ridiculous looking suit and was replaced
shortly into the production with Kevin
Peter Hall if you ask a million people
what their favorite Disney animated
movies you'll likely hear the words
Chicken Little a grand total of zero
times the 2005 theatrical feature is the
46th animated movie from the house of
mouse and holds the distinction of being
the first fully computer animated movie
in the studio's library Disney got
pretty far into production with actress
Holly Hunter voicing the lead role of
Chicken Little before the decision was
made to pivot the movie into more of an
action-packed adventure and subsequently
reimagine the protagonist as a boy
instead of a girl after eight months of
voice-over work on hunters paths she was
replaced by scrub star Zach Braff whose
voice was pitched up in post-production
but if
has any hard feelings about being kicked
out of the coop by Disney they haven't
soured her relationship with the company
she would like to return to Disney Pixar
for another go-around as Elastigirl in
the 2018 sequel to 2004 The Incredibles
1974's the Lords of Flatbush originally
starred Richard Gere as part of an
ensemble cast of leather jacket wearing
hoodlums along with the Sylvester
Stallone and Henry Winkler reportedly
gear was removed from the production as
a result of a feud with Stallone that
spun out of control as you might expect
Stallone side of the story places the
blame on Gere who according to Stallone
was impossible to deal with but gears
departure was ultimately triggered by a
sloppy lunch on set with gear spilling
mustard onto Stallone's pants while they
were scarfing down food in the back seat
of a Toyota in a 2006 interview with
Ain't It Cool News Stallone explained I
elbowed him in the side of the head and
basically pushed him out the car the
director had to make a choice one of us
had to go one of us had to stay Richard
was given his walking papers and to this
day seriously dislikes me playing a Mars
character in a movie is always a risky
proposition if the audience can't see
your lips move there's a serious risk
that your performance will go the way of
David Prowse is Darth Vader with your
vocals over dubbed by another actor who
then gets all the credit and that's
exactly what happened to James Purefoy
in 2005's V for Vendetta
beneath this mask of there's more than
flesh
beneath this mask there was an idea mr.
greedy and ideas are multiple Purefoy
was originally cast in the Wachowski
produced political movie as the masked
revolutionary known as V however he quit
before filming could be completed while
no reasons for his departure were given
at the time it was later reported that
the actor quits due to frustration with
his costume according to a later
interview Purefoy gave to Total Film
these rumors are untrue Purefoy stated
that his departure came down to genuine
creative differences that eventually
became intolerable though he was
replaced by Hugo Weaving
some of his performance was left in the
finished film Hugh Jackman
single-handedly made Wolverine into an
icon through his soulful sorrowful
portrayal of the nigh unkillable mutant
in the x-men franchise but when the
first movie entered production in 1999
Jackman had yet to enter the picture
originally the cigar-chomping role of
Logan was to be played by Scottish actor
Dougray Scott but his participation in
the superhero movie was held up by
production delays on John woos mission
impossible to production on x-men had
already begun while Scott was working on
the Mission Impossible sequel but the
combination of that movie's delays and a
shoulder injury Scott sustained made it
impossible for him to make it to work on
time after a month's worth of filming
with the rest of x-men's cast Scott's
was set to join the production just over
a week before his expected arrival
however it became clear that the
arrangement wouldn't work so Fox began a
speedy search for a replacement
Wolverine patience is my strongest suit
a relatively unknown Hugh Jackman was
cast in the role soon after and the rest
is history
[Music]